You just said that and feel free to repeat it again.
Germany's position is clear Israel has every right to defend itself against Mr.
Mass' terrorist attack and we have always made that clear in the last few days,
weeks and months.
And it remains so.
Israel can also rely on that.
Again,
what I have already said Germany has a special
and a good relationship with Israel.
This is very important to us and therefore Israel can rely on us.
We have a clear position on what is needed now.
This includes the release of the hostages,
this includes humanitarian aid,
this includes the prospect of a 2-state solution.
You cannot find the Solution bei bei bei getting so ähm äh One sided in
Terms of Looking Only One particular Issue and Erase sixty years of atrocities
the Solution is Not just releasing the hostages what about the settelments
what about the behavior the of the Sietelus now continues
daily what about this possession,
the Land,
the Right,
the Dignity,
the Men,
the Women,
the Children are These so no concern.